In this segment we start
a new topic.
We will talk about the
covariance of two random
variables, which gives us useful
information about the
dependencies between these
two random variables.
Let us motivate the concept
by looking first
at a special case.
Suppose that X and Y have zero
means and that they there are
discrete random variables.
If X and Y are independent, then
the expectation of the
product is the product
of the expectations.
And since we have assumed zero
means, this is going to be
equal to zero.
But suppose instead that the
joint PMF of X and Y is of the
following kind.
Each point in this diagram is
equally likely, so we have
here a discrete uniform
distribution on the discrete
set which consists of the points
shown in this diagram.
What we have in this particular
example is that at
most outcomes, positive values
of X tend to go together with
positive values of Y. And
negative values of X tend to
go together with negative values
of Y. So most of the
time we have outcomes in this
quadrant, in which x times y
is positive, or in this quadrant
where x times y is,
again, positive.
But some of the time we fall in
this quadrant where x times
y is negative, or in
this quadrant where
x times y is negative.
Since we have many more points
here and here, on the average,
the value of x times y is
going to be positive.
On the other hand, if the
diagram takes this form, then,
most of the time, the pair x, y
lies in this quadrant or in
that quadrant where
the product of
x times y is negative.
So the random variables X and
Y typically have opposite
signs, and on the average, the
expected value of X times Y is
going to be negative.
So here we have a positive
expectation, here we have a
negative expectation of X times
Y. This quantity, the
expected value of X times Y,
tells us whether X and Y tend
to move in the same or in
opposite directions.
And this quantity is what we
call the covariance, in the
zero mean case.
Let us now generalize.
The random variables do not
have to be discrete.
This quantity is well
defined for any
kind of random variables.
And if we have non-zero means,
the covariance is defined by
this expression.
What we have here is that we
look at the deviation of X
from its mean value, and the
deviation of Y from its mean
value, and we're asking whether
these two deviations
tend to have the same sign or
not, whether they move in the
same direction or not.
If the covariance is positive,
what it tells us is that
whenever this quantity is
positive so that X is above
its mean, then, typically or
usually, the deviation of Y
from its mean will also
tend to be positive.
To summarize, the covariance,
in general, tells us whether
two random variables tend to
move together, both being high
or both being low, in some
average or typical sense.
Now, if the two random variables
are independent, we
already saw that in the zero
mean case, this quantity--
the covariance--
is going to be 0.
How about the case where
we have non-zero means?
Well, if we have independence,
then we have the expected
value of the product of
two random variables.
X and Y are independent, so X
minus the expected value,
which is a constant, is going to
be independent from Y minus
its expected value.
And so, the covariance is going
to be the product of two
expectations.
But the expected value of X
minus this constant is 0, and
the same is true for
this term as well.
So the covariance in this case
is going to be equal to 0.
So in the independent case,
we have zero covariances.
On the other hand, the
converse is not true.
There are examples in which we
have dependence but zero
covariance.
Here is one example.
In this example there are
four possible outcomes.
At any particular outcome,
either X or Y
is going to be 0.
So in this example the random
variable X times Y is
identically equal to 0.
The mean of X is also 0, the
mean of Y is also 0 by
symmetry, so the covariance
is the expected
value of this quantity.
And so the covariance, in this
example, is equal to 0.
On the other hand, the
two random variables,
X and Y, are dependent.
If I tell you that X is equal to
1, then you know that this
outcome has occurred.
And in that case, you are
certain that Y is equal to 0.
So knowing the value of X tells
you a lot about the
value of Y and, therefore, we
have dependence between these
two random variables.